Ovo je učinite primule,
imamo pravnih pravila,
ko su ona pravila
koja ima uređeno pričavljivno države.
Omenuli smo dva osnovna
principa pričavljivne države.
To je koja su poznano,
če je sugoordinacija i koordinacija.
Subordinacija je odnos nadređenosti
i podređenosti,
koji imamo državno gade
na različitom stebrnom glasom.
A kod koordinacije imamo isti
stepne vlasti i imamo saradnje.
To je ono što smo u proško u srpu radili
i gdje smo se zavustali.
Sada idemo dalje.
Dakle, kada je reč o ljudima,
krenut ćemo sa ljudima
da vidimo koju to ljudi rade,
šta rade, kako rade, kakav je njihov
odnos prema državi kao organizaciju.
Dakle, državu kao organizaciju ne
čine svi građani, ne čini svojstavni
nešto. Taj državni aparat čini samo neki
ljudi. Ti ljudi čine taj državni aparat,
oni se nazivaju državnim
skužbenom ljicima.
To su ljudi
koji rade u ime izračenom državnim.
E sad, tim državnim službenim
licima se daju opređenom poslu.
Zatakle imate opređene državne službenice,
Dašem da radi neki posao
i taj posao predstavljam neku nadležnju.
Budim dobro što jednostavnije objasniti.
Ne da se držim tih definicijeg družbenika,
nebo najprostije je moguće
da ono objasniti.
Dakle, uzmeš neki posao,
daš ga jednom državnom službenom više
i kaži, evo ti nadležnje.
To je tvoja nadležnost.
Uplavno tako.
E sada,
postoje dve vrste nadražnosti u principu
i ova treća nekakva funkcionalna, te
uopšte nije zakonska kategorija,
ali se često spominje koja ćemo nju
objasniti i prisutna je naravno u gradu,
državni štodana,
ali nije zakonska kategorija.
Da krenemo od stvarne, dakle,
ako uzmete recimo jednog sudima
koji je državno spužbeno lice
i jednog narodnog poslanika
koji je državno spužbeno lice.
Da li oni radi isti